I'm angry with all of you because you
didn't go see a lot of the best movies
of the year but you can play catch up
thanks to my list of the top 10 most
underrated movies of 2014 on this week's
episode of angry nerd okay everyone
agrees that television is in the middle
of a Golden Age or platinum age
dilithium age whatever there are all of
these terrific compelling challenging
series from HBO AMC Showtime Netflix
Amazon but feature-length movies that
play in theaters are actually still
pretty good if you know where to look
which come to think of it will probably
be your TV screen at this point oh well
there are 10 overlooked films that truly
deserve your attention Jim Jarmusch's
flick was the most compelling depiction
of vampires I've seen in years I mean
come on if Dracula was real he wouldn't
be a blockbuster action hero laying
waste to rival armies or a sparkly teen
heartthrob canoodling with a twitchy
wooden actress he would waste his days
lounging around and sucking on gourmet
blood sickles like the decadent
Eurotrash that he is this half
live-action half animated adaptation of
Stanislaw LEM s classic sci-fi satire is
easily the most mind-bending film of the
year Robin Wright is terrific as an
actress who sells her likeness rights to
Hollywood and then crosses over into a
strange hallucinogenic alternate
universe it's like ralph bakshi school
world if ralph bakshi school world was
not absolutely terrible
now you'd hardly know it from the ad
campaign but this clever no budget
dramedy about two couples in their
unusual relationship issues has a huge
sci-fi twist it's really odd saying more
would spoil it just just be sure to
check it out what a relief to see an
action movie with almost no dialogue or
plot or special effects to distract from
the action bonus Google around to find a
video of director Gareth Evans
discussing his top 5 favorite fight
scenes of all time his list is one of my
top 5 top 5 lists Stephen Chow is like a
cross between Jackie Chan and Peter
Jackson a master of slapstick comedy
martial arts and digital effects now
he's been all but ignored stateside
since Kung Fu Hustle
but this adaptation of a classic 16th
century Chinese novel is worth tracking
down the greatest sci-fi flick of the
1970s was never actually filmed cult
director Alejandro Jodorowsky's planned
adaptation of Frank Herbert's novel dune
collapsed under the weight of its own
ambitions before it made it off the
drawing board but the sketchy outline
that survives which is lovingly
presented in this new documentary
captures the imagination in ways that
few actual produced sci-fi flicks do a
South Korean adaptation of a French
science fiction comic starring Captain
America sold its depiction of a class
war aboard a high-tech train rocketing
around a ruined earth is this
thought-provoking as it is thrilling
this film made a bundle overseas but it
bombed stateside what is wrong with us
America this satire of rom-com cliches
starring Amy Poehler and Paul Rudd was a
hoot some griped
that it arrived too late to really
skewer its source material seriously
that's like saying what hot American
summer is a failure because it was
released two decades after meatballs
hyaaah Miyazaki is great now but Esau
Takahata is the unsung anime genius of
Studio Ghibli the directors newest
release an adaptation of a Japanese
folktale came and went from theaters but
it ranks right up there with this
classics like pom Poko and grave of the
fireflies
let's pour one out for lived I repeat
the Tom Cruise movie formerly known as
edge of tomorrow doug liman terrific
adaptation of the clever Japanese sci-fi
novel was the best blockbuster of the
year and it should have been a huge hit
but it bombs so terribly that the studio
renamed it for the DVD release the way
its protagonists continually gets to
relive the last 48 hours over and over
and over again now this is a Tom Cruise
movie that even Tom Cruise haters could
love thanks to the Groundhog Day style
story structure you get to see him die
dozens and dozens of times I stand by
everything I said about it at the time
of its release it's the best movie ever
made about videogames even though it's
not about videogames maybe I'll go back
in time and warn the studio not to give
it such a lame title and I'll also warn
myself not to eat that ceviche from
7-eleven by the way I hate top-ten lists
it's such an arbitrary limitation I wish
it was a top 67 list so I could have
included cooties open windows the rover
enemy the double zero theorem automata
blue ruin coherence stretch the babadook
under the skin the vanquishing of the
witch Bobby you got hey don't fade out
I'm not done yet a most wanted man to be
Takei the Galapagos affair Alan
Partridge what do you think is the most
underrated movie of 2014
let me know in the comments and click
down here to subscribe for more angry
nerd and you can check out more of my
reviews as well as other great clips
from Wired by clicking on any of feet
any of any of these click on any of
these over here you're right